alright let me start this video off by
saying a big fat spoiler alert if you
have not beaten Metal Gear Solid 5 the
phantom pain
spoiler alert right here if you want to
see my spoiler free review I got it it's
right there it's in the link in the
description
no spoilers whatsoever spoiler free to
the tenth degree before we get into this
I gotta say because I forgot to mention
it in my review and I don't know how
Kiefer Sutherland as big boss was
awesome I love David Hayter I will
always love him as Solid Snake and young
big boss but it was inevitable they
would have to switch voice actors for
big boss because all the sneaking big
boss are not genetically identical to
each other so at a point they will sound
different Kiefer Sutherland did a great
job in this game his voice is perfect in
fact when I saw 24 no [ __ ] I called
him solid a snake I swear might be
random might be destiny it's now done
it's now said now we're going to talk
about the most divisive thing I've seen
in Metal Gear Solid yet so now let's get
down to business we're at the end of
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain
dropped a bomb in everyone's lap it
pulled the pin it dropped it it said
Merry Christmas Happy New Year peace
boom that twist is the fact that you
actually aren't playing his big boss in
this game he's another guy entirely he's
the medic who ripped a bomb out of paws
and ground zeroes now he has shrapnel in
his head he lost his arm wakes up in a
hospital and there was this really fishy
parts like hey you've looked like this
forever in this big boss's face so now
you got to reconstruct your face so here
we go
so you make this other person this
avatar and after surgery is like alright
now you look like this and it's what
you've chosen then he gets out of the
bed and he looks like Big Boss again I
was like that's a weird thing what did
they do there and then you meet Ishmael
who has Kiefer Sutherland's boys I
thought Ishmael was going to be solid as
snake because he's the genetic identical
but it turns out when you beat the game
it reveals Ishmael is actually the real
Big Boss and that plastic surgery was
taking you from the Avatar that you
chose into big boss's face it was
actually reversed I show you this other
guy and through hypnotherapy and all
that [ __ ] that made Ocelot think he was
liquid snake and Metal Gear Solid 4 now
he thinks he's Big Boss and I completely
get it this video is not going to
convince you why you're wrong and hating
it if you hate this ending I do
understand there was a knee-jerk
reaction I had after it was all revealed
and went to credits I said out loud I
was like I don't like this but then I
was I was going in circles in my living
room as the credits were rolling I was
like alright how does this piece
together how does it fit and it clicked
in my head and I guess I didn't have to
pace and really think
because Ocelot spills it well from what
I've seen in forums and blogs people are
still pissed about this from what I've
seen it's for a couple different reasons
first of all they feel like Big Boss is
going to live on a beach somewhere and
this other guy you play as in this game
is Big Boss forever that wouldn't make
any sense even in Metal Gear Solid 4
they reconstruct Big Boss with solid ass
snake who's a genetic identical and how
could they do that if this other guy was
now Big Boss to be like oh he's totally
not his clone yeah I guess he's just
gonna look like [ __ ] forever so Big Boss
is still around Big Boss still does [ __ ]
Big Boss still stands get cypher stands
against the Patriots ciphers are
precursor to the Patriots keep that in
mind so when I say cypher or the
Patriots I'm really talking about the
same entity but what you find out is
this guy you play us in Metal Gear Solid
5 venom snake the Phantom Big Boss is
big boss from Metal Gear 1 like original
old-school Metal Gear one solid snake
kills you always heard and believed that
Solid Snake kills him and then he just
comes back and does his ends up our
thing so he has to go and kill him again
but I'm not going to lie to you guys
this laid to rest the biggest thing that
was in my head I was like that doesn't
make any sense in the first Metal Gear
big boss is the commander that's giving
Solid Snake orders on Kodak but then you
find out he's the big bad guy in outer
heaven he's like now we got a fight and
I was always like I want to see Kojima
explained this [ __ ] if he ever gets the
story up to that where he has to remake
those games because it just doesn't make
any sense in the game they write it off
something like well I wanted to bring
you here so you'd bring back false
information but you're just too good as
a soldier so now we got to fight and
kill each other and his storytelling
goes nowadays it just it's too hard to
do and it just doesn't make any sense I
was just always curious how he would do
that it's almost like there were two big
bosses and that's what he's created he
has created a second big boss and I
believe it so that makes sense so I
think the real big boss gives Solid
Snake orders to go to outer heaven and
kill the venom snake phantom big boss in
Metal Gear 1 it also makes more sense
for gray fox grey fox is a powa in the
first Metal Gear game and the second
Metal Gear game he's working with big
boss he's like yeah big boss saved my
ass so I kind of have allegiance to him
so I own so why was he a powa original
Metal Gear game it doesn't make sense
that big boss would just capture him and
then after that's like hey by the way
before I met you he it was actually
awesome it's like they're two different
big bosses so the phantom big boss is
doing the outer heaven thing for Metal
Gear 1 he's doing that so all eyes are
on him his big boss I get big bosses
over there he's doing that thing slifer
knows where he
so the real Big Boss can do the Zanzibar
uprising under the radar the Zanzibar
uprising is ultimately the real outer
heaviness with Ocelot calls and then I
had fun piecing together like all right
why would Big Boss have Solid Snake take
out the Phantom Big Boss say at first I
was thinking maybe he has
Solid Snake take him out so everyone
thinks big boss is dead so again he can
do the Zanzibar thing and everyone's
like vote big boss is dead that's
clearly not him doing that or maybe and
I'm actually more inclined to believe
this is actually the reason for it I
think the phantom pain big boss becomes
a dick seriously I think he becomes an
[ __ ] like that scene where he has to
wipe out everybody who has the the
bacteria and their throats and he's
walking its horns getting bigger and its
face looks like a skull and just really
ominous looking even takes the ashes and
licks it and like puts it over his face
there like this guy might be going out
of his mind and what we saw the original
big boss and peace walker using nuke as
a deterrent and no one would mess with
them I feel like this big boss is gonna
make nukes but use them as a threat more
than deterrence he's like you know what
I'm gonna threaten the world now and I
think the original big boss is like yeah
that can't happen I need to take him out
so ultimately now this scenario you can
see it as it doesn't detract from Big
Boss it ultimately adds to his heroism
he takes this dude out for the sake of
people around the world that's awesome
but that also does conflict with another
reason I've seen people are pissed at
this because they wanted this game to be
what shows the fall of Big Boss you know
show him to decline into villainy like
they've wanted to see all along you play
this game and it does look like it's
doing that but personally for me I
didn't think Big Boss was supposed to be
the villain correction I thought Big
Boss was the villain I always heard he
was up through Metal Gear Solid 2 and
then Metal Gear Solid 3 Snake Eater came
out and by the end of that you're like I
don't think this is supposed to be a
villain I think he's a good soldier who
ends up getting screwed and murdered and
killed because he's an inconvenience if
Metal Gear Solid works the way I think
Metal Gear Solid Works the future echoes
the past so when I saw the boss
ultimately get screwed over by the
government and the snake had to kill her
and then the boss's reputation she goes
down in history as someone who defected
to the Soviet Union who was going to
cause a nuclear war and that's just not
the case she was like this huge hero
she's the Severus Snape without someone
actually knowing the truth who can talk
about it boy so after Big Boss flew to
grave and the tear comes down the aisle
was like I think that's
thing happens to him I don't think he
was this big [ __ ] we always heard he
was keep in mind cipher of the Patriots
whatever you want to call him they
gained a lot of political power by the
time big boss is doing the whole
Zanzibar thing and that's why big boss
created the nation of Zanzibar it's a
nation that's free of outside government
free of control of the Patriots and he
did that so he can move against the
Patriots and take the Patriots out Saul
the Patriots had to do his feed Solid
Snake and Roy Campbell some [ __ ]
story about some big [ __ ] who's this
huge threat to the world over there in
Zanzibar saw the snake goes over there
takes out Big Boss ultimately is still
alive but Salah snake believes that he
has done the best thing possible as a
model American soldier but all he really
was was a gun to the Patriots histories
written by the victors the victors being
the Patriots and now Big Boss goes down
in history as a villain even though what
he wanted to do is take out the villains
oh [ __ ] what it just came to me Seifer
the Patriots their eyes are on venom
snake big boss over there in outer
heaven other big boss is safely tucked
away because no one knows he exists what
if real big boss sends solid snake to
kill venom snake big boss knowing that
it would expose him to the Patriots but
if he had to take out venom snake to
save the world knowing it would mean his
own demise adding even more to his
heroism and tragedy i theorize this
because it's fun but in the end we all
never know granted I'm not saying big
bosses this shining White Knight hero
he's definitely a mercenary he
definitely got some [ __ ] wrong even
Telus saw the snake at the end of four
he's like we were a bunch of old fools
who started something we shouldn't have
started so we're all going to die now
and the world will be better for it Eva
said he and Zira misinterpreted the
bosses Wilson I mean that's all still
there the guy who killed the boss the
guy who saluted her grave the guy who
walked away from the United States still
does everything you heard about in
Zanzibar just not the initial outer
heaven up rivals ultimately you can look
at the twist in Metal Gear Solid 5 the
phantom pain like riding in Metal Gear
Solid 2 not playing a Solid Snake in
Metal Gear Solid 2 pissed me off it
pissed me off for a very long time until
the saga was complete by the end of four
I looked back and I was like for the
scope of the entire story it actually
does work better the Metal Gear Solid is
more than the sum of one character in
the sum of one game it is a world
constructed - looking at this as one
entry to one chapter in a larger story
makes me step back and go yeah it's
bigger than that I think the biggest
thing that leaves a taste of vinegar in
your mouth and it still does for me is
the fact that this is it is
what we get I really feel like Hideo
Kojima was going to make another game
another chapter that ties this all in it
makes you go oh that actually does work
out now I see that because there's
another game or two out kijima has
always said every Metal Gear Solid's
gonna be his last game you've said he
said that since three so if he said hey
this is my last metal gear solid before
Konami actually made that a definite
statement I wouldn't believe it I would
be like yeah you have another game
coming and that would be something to
look forward to maybe you see at the end
of the next Metal Gear Solid game the
last mission is you play a Solid Snake
and you infiltrate under heaven then you
take out venom snake and he's like oh
the bastard did it I don't know I feel
like the next game with time or [ __ ]
together so we'd all step back and go
okay I was kind of pissed for years and
now I'm not but the fact is this is what
we get we got a bomb dropped in our laps
and it was like hey peace that's the
last thing that happens in Metal Gear
for you there's nothing to look forward
to maybe Konami will release another
Metal Gear Solid game but it won't be
what kijima was going to do who knows
what he was going to do after this I
feel like in maybe in 50 years he'll
tell us and again as I bring this video
to a close this is not me telling you
that you're wrong if you hate this twist
I get it I'm just telling you how my
brain kind of work how I took the
information how I process the
information how I have dealt with that
information that's how I see it that's
how I saw this twist that's how I think
this twist can work that's how I think
it does work and that's why I actually
ended up liking this twist after the
knee-jerk reaction to getting pissed
like everyone else everybody who likes
this twist at least for that long was
like boy hey hey hey but now I'm curious
as to what you thought about it so the
Metal Gear Solid 5 phantom pain ending
twist what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more